all right uh still cryptic when it comes
to what's happening with julio jones the
window opened yesterday for a trade the
fact that the falcons have not yet
traded julio jones tells us they're not
happy with whatever offers they have
gotten and we still have not heard
anything firm the closest we've heard is
a first round picks on the table and i
was told over the weekend that to get
the first round pick the falcons are
going to have to give up julio jones
plus something else maybe as much as a
second round pick so it ain't really a
first round pick for julio jones so
either way they're not happy with what's
been offered while they've been shopping
this guy for six weeks now arthur smith
coach of the atlanta falcons was asked
yesterday about julio jones and
specifically whether he'll be at
mandatory minicamp here's the question
and the answer from the first year coach
of the falcons
we have conversations all the time with
all our players
there's good communication going back
and forth through multiple uh avenues so
we'll see what happens next week where
we're at you know so
i can answer that for you next week
obviously the question was not there and
that was on me i misread the throat i
can't even read kid can't even i can't
even read it i can't i look down at it
and i thought it said starts with
question and it did not regardless
arthur smith has been great at
deflecting any and all questions about
julio jones annie and all he's like he's
like a goalie in in game seven of the
stanley cup finals and he's he's in his
groove and he's ready to go hoist the
cup he has been impenetrable and the
falcons for the most part have done a
very good job but for shannon sharpe's
cold call that created a hot mess for
him in fs1
jones we'd even have no idea that this
was in any way shape or form about julio
jones wanting out but we know he wants
out he ain't going to be a mandatory man
it can't be you kidding me i'm out of
there what what part hey hey reporters
who asked about julio jones what part if
i'm out of there don't you understand
yeah he isn't going to be a mandatory
mini-cam nor do they want him to be what
do they don't want him to go there and
blow a hamstring or a pull a quad muscle
and then they can't trade him at all so
they don't want them that you know from
that they don't want a mandatory mini
camp and it doesn't sound like they
really
want him either go ahead what
no no no next level yeah julio jones
show up
you wanna you want to get a trade done
show up at mandatory minute camp it
reminds me of what happened when the
titans were done with steve mcnair yeah
they were ready to turn the page to
vince young right they locked him out of
the facility there was a big grievance
there was a big fight and he ultimately
was traded to the ravens but the titans
wanted to say no you're not welcome
because they didn't want him to get
injured right he had like an 11 million
dollar cap figure which was a big deal
at the time they didn't want that so if
julio jones really wants to push this
and i don't think he's wired to do that
he handles his business privately and
discreetly if he really wants to push it
show up hey here i am deal with me and
yeah if i get injured you owe me 15.3
million this year you better trade me
yeah take what you can get and move on
it can put pressure even if it gets into
that situation they'd probably just
they'd limit his reps you know he did
probably or tell him not to practice i
don't know what they would do you know
they'd have to have a sit down talk with
him and be like hey listen we're trying
to trade you we don't want you to come
out here do this all right so hey great
it's great you're here we're doing our
best we'll see so it does put pressure
on the situation but i don't think it's
going to like make the falcons fold you
know what i mean that way but it quickly
becomes a union issue it does
to not let him have full and complete
access
to mandatory mini camp to get ready for
the season it it can get messy quickly i
don't think he wants it i know they
don't want it but you know what i mean
think about it from his perspective when
do i get my new team i want my new team
falcons you're not being reasonable i
mean julio through his agent jimmy
sexton surely knows what's been offered
oh sure there's a chance that behind the
curtain they're saying take the offer
take the offer take the offer send me to
tennessee let's go let's get this done
i'm not saying there's an offer from
tennessee i'm just saying
he knows what's out there yeah take it
quit being so stubborn i want to move on
right jimmy sexton knows everybody he's
been around for a long time i'm sure
they have a really good gauge of the
market and everything like that i don't
know as we sit here and we get closer
and closer to the end of otas mini camps
and now the break
i feel like um
we're not it's not going to happen right
now
that's just the way i feel about it now
i feel like it's going to be one of
those training camp things a little bit
because of what we set they're gonna be
like wait we don't really want him here
and get hurt so he's here at training
camp and you know maybe they can
maximize what they get too with the old
adage of like we've we've talked about
this in the past a team gets into
training camp hey of course an injury
can happen but you get through sometimes
teams get through the first week or two
of training camp and get through the
preseason game and they they look at
their roster and they go
we we need another receiver we just this
we have one guy and that's it and we
need more like so we're we got to do
something here we got a good team this
is a real piece we're missing and maybe
that's how atlanta can maximize their
leverage by just waiting it out to see
if one of those type of teams kind of
comes you know comes up comes about once
training camp starts to and pre-season
games get here
you know chris before
the shannon sharp phone call and the i'm
out of their response
we had presented one scenario where the
falcons have to move forward and trade
him during training camp during the
season as teams start to realize where
they are in the super bowl hierarchy
exactly maybe somebody would offer more
when you consider that muhammad sunu
yielded a second round pick and emanuel
sanders a third round pick during the
2019 season to the patriots and
and 49ers respectively
maybe this will be the first time that a
team says to a guy you just stay home
you stay home could be we're gonna we're
gonna let this play out right training
camp preseason regular season you stay
in shape you keep posting on instagram
that you're in shape so everyone knows
you're in shape and and maybe they trade
him
from whatever
designation they find to put him in
and and and then
they don't have to worry about him
getting injured he doesn't have to come
back he doesn't want to come back but
they hold on to that asset until a team
gets into october and says we gotta have
julio jones let's increase the price and
let's make it happen that's that's now
on the radar screen i think so that's
that's the benefit of talking this stuff
out yeah i don't know if i ever would
have thought of that if we weren't kind
of working through these angles but but
i i think him we're getting to that
getting permission to not show up
i think that that that may be the only
thing the falcons can do if they truly
want to maximize it then the question is
they want that distraction every day
every week every practice every whatever
and if they do if it's more important
than to get what they want that's a way
to do it that's right you know they just
have to be you know
honest about the situation yeah i mean
yeah we gotta answer questions but this
is the deal we've told julio this
you know our marriage has come to an end
we love him he's a legend he's one of
the best players in the history of the
organization he wants out it's probably
best for us right now so we're trying to
make a deal and make it happen i mean
yeah i i think we're getting closer to
that too mike that's i mean we're here
at you know the the mini camps and all
of that to where
be patient atlanta now at this point and
you know i want to ask you this i mean
do you think like
the public pressure of that sunu trade
and the second round pick is affecting
the falcons at all it's just as far as
yeah you do right i mean me too arthur
blank is determined to at least get a
second round yeah i agree determined
yeah determined and and even then
they're having a hard time accepting it
i know they are right they got a two for
muhammad sununu and chris they gave up a
two for hayden hirsch yeah that's the
other side of this it doesn't get
discussed
now they gave up a two and a five and
got hurst and a four
it's basically a two yeah that that's
the other reason they can't wrap their
arms around this this is a tight end
they didn't even pick up his fifth year
option oh and they gave up a second
round pick for this guy yeah yeah i mean
i feel like that is definitely playing
you know a factor at least playing in
this situation there's no doubt i mean
you look on social media you know and
again not that those people are
knowledgeable but that's the chatter oh
well if they got sunu for a second round
they should at least get a first round
for julio jones i think they got to be a
little worried about kind of being
eviscerated publicly in their own city
with how this
the optics of this situation look so uh
there might the best leverage i think
they have at this point right now is to
wait it out a little bit i think like
you like we've talked about we flushed
it out training camp maybe you get a
team desperate there if not yep wait for
that trade the trade deadline see what
teams are in the super bowl window
they're going wait we're we're good you
know we're we're six or five and two and
we got a chance to be in the super bowl
we're missing one key piece let's go all
in and that's maybe where they can get
their first round pick and and get what
they want
they have yet to do as far as i've seen
any type of pr effort working on
reporters to get them to spread this
news that hey it's different with julio
j he's older he's got 15.3 million fully
guaranteed this year he's going to
possibly want a new contract when he
goes to a new team it's not as simple
and straightforward oh and it's
pre-season pre-pre-season it's not when
a team feels like hey let's go roll the
dice and go all in yeah we think we can
get to a super bowl there's a lot of
factors out there that i don't feel like
they're pushing the one thing that i've
noticed is you've you've seen multiple
reporters say i think they'll take a
second-round pick for them and i feel
like that's coming from the falcons with
the don't report this just present it as
your own idea caveat but even then they
either haven't gotten a second round
pick a firm second round pick where the
new team pays the full 15.3 million that
they did before the draft they haven't
gotten it since or they've yet to still
come to terms with the idea of taking a
second round pick at the end of the day
this is a bus that is being driven by
arthur blank he's the one who's got his
finger on the button as to whether or
not they're going to accept the trade
offers and you may have some people in
the organization saying let's just move
on from this blank
doesn't want to move on until at a
minimum he gets that second round pick
and either he hasn't gotten it or he's
still holding out for that first round
yeah no i mean it seems that way we'll
see where it's going i mean it's crazy
you know aaron rodgers julio jones i
mean we're talking about two guys here
in the first segment of the show who
don't want to be with their team their
first ballot hall of famers and uh it's
crazy situation it's gonna be fun to
watch it really is because i don't think
there's any you know definitive writing
on the wall here to where either
situation is gonna go and i mean julio
we know he's i mean i feel like
definitely gonna get traded i just don't
know when
or you know for what and when exactly it
does happening goes down and that's
where it's a little delicate this whole
situation
and and this idea of putting him on ice
and waiting that that really may end up
being the winner here if they are
determined to get more than what they
currently can get
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports